sylvie vartan ou on vous présente parce
que je crois que ce sont vos débuts noms
sont vos débuts non ce n'est pas une
astuce publicitaires et sylvie vartan la
nouvelle vedette de la chanson i twist
et bien cette jeune lycéenne de 17 ans
et que nous voyons sortir d'un des
grands lycées de paris le cas nous a
paru assez exceptionnel pas que nous
vous le présentions et vient souligner
si vous nous rabotez nouvelle histoire
histoire être simple j'ai eu une enfance
tu as fait banal j'ai suivi comme tout
le monde les cours ont listé jusqu'au
jour où tout à fait par hasard j'ai
commencé en chante à chanter avec
francky jourdan vous n'aviez jamais eu
l'envié de chanter de devenir chanteuse
oh non mon rêve c'était surtout de faire
du théâtre mais par le chant non ça ne
les empêche leur ai dit et c'est une
chance qui est arrivé en pleine
préparation de base que vous préparez
votre premier bal oui et alors vous avez
vous avez décidé de continuer quand même
premièrement le bac dans quelques mois
ça aurait été vraiment dommage de
laisser tomber et c'est quand même
indispensable pour quoi on a un point de
vue culturel et même pour une chanteuse
c'est un pensez que c'est lui les
rassemble oui lorsque on vous a proposé
cet engagement dans la pièce que vous en
avez parlé oui c'est au nom n'y a que
mes meilleurs amis qui étaient dans la
confidence lorsque vous voulez
absolument pas être considéré comme une
bête curieuse oh non parce qu'il n'y a
vraiment rien d'extraordinaire à ce que
je suis mes cours en même temps il n'y a
rien d'extraordinaire ce que vous seriez
devenue une chanteuse
peut-être